It's just over a week
since a furious bird's nest
was elected president,
and many peop...
Oh, they're getting out
right there.
The birds are getting out.
People are still very afraid
because it's not just civil
liberties being threatened.
It's also shiny things.
The Donald has promised
to tax imports from China,
-which could...
-Wow.
raise the price of the iPhone,
not to mention his plan to ban
all iPhones that aren't white.
-Uh, this...
-(laughter) -Wow.
-Listen, you know...
-(cheers and applause)
These phones...
This potential $50 to $97
increase is,
of course,
most concerning to liberals
since many Trump supporters
prefer to communicate
-through illuminati fluoride
brainwaves. -(laughter)
So, comedians, how else
might Trump's presidency
affect the new iPhones?
James Davis.
-Now you can grab Siri
by the pussy. -All right.
(laughter,
cheers and applause)
(imitating Siri):
Please don't do that right now.
Uh, Dan Levy.
It works a lot better than you
expected... in the red states.
-HARDWICK: All right.
Uh, points. -(laughter)
Arielle.
He'll bring back
the headphone jack,
-and suddenly, everyone will
love him. -DAVIS: Yes.
HARDWICK:
Yeah, that's all he's got to do.
-(applause) -Yes.
-That's all he's got to do
is put the headphone jack back
where it belongs.
We need it!